[ YouTube Learning ]
One thing we love as teachers
is to know if our students have
really understood concepts.
And how can we do that?
By giving them quizzes and assignments;
That's right!
and Google Classroom has made that really easy!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
On your Google Classroom dashboard,
you can pick the Class
you’d like to add questions
or assignments to.
And then you can head over
to the ClassWork section!
Once you click on CREATE,
you will see 3 options
that will help you assess
the understanding level of students.
You could give the students Long Form Assignments,
or graded quizzes,
or you could also ask them
just one simple question.
Let’s look at the options one by one.
If you wish to give your students an assignment,
or some task,
the first option works best.
For instance,
you may want to ask your students
“What does the word LINEAR mean?
Explain using text and images”.
So we just have to click on Create,
and select ‘Assignment’.
First, you will need to enter some basic information.
After that,
you can add a file from Google Drive.
Google Drive is a place where
you can store your files on remote servers,
and NOT on your local machine or laptop.
The data here is completely safe
and no one can really access your files
unless you give anyone
the permission to do so!
You can access your files whenever you feel like.
Let’s now add a document you want to share!
Here it is!
At this point,
Google Classroom gives you an interesting option.
It asks you
“what it is that
you’d want your students to do with this file?”
Should they be able to just view it?
Can all students edit your same file?
Or automatically make a
different copy for each student.
You can then select
the most appropriate option for yourself....
select the details on the right….
and click ‘Assign’.
How will the students see it?
Let’s move to the student view now!
The students will then be able to see
the assignment on their dashboard.
After they click on it,
they will see this screen.
The students will now be able to see
the copy created for them by you.
They can click on it,
and write their answer in the same file.
If there is something else
the students have to share,
they can add their work using the
Add or Create option they see here.
After the student is done,
they can then click on Turn in
to submit their work.
It’ll ask the students for the confirmation,
and then it’s done!
If the student submits it by mistake
or if the student feels like adding
or editing the assignment,
the student can also unsubmit it
and then submit it again
Let’s switch back to the teacher view!
We will look at the second option of
“Quiz Assignment” in much greater detail
in the next lesson.
For now
let’s look at how you can simply add
a SINGLE question to the class,
which is the third option!
Clicking on QUESTION
will get you to this page.
Note that this is used only
if you want to add a SINGLE question
and not a series of questions.
You can then enter your question,
and add some instructions with it…
You can then pick if
it’s a short answer question
or a multiple choice.
Let’s pick multiple choice,
and add 4 options.
If you want your students to visit
a particular link or a youtube video,
you can do that by clicking on Add.
And you can also add documents
or presentations for their reference,
using the other options.
You can then decide
if you wish to share it with all students,
or just a few.
You could either assign marks
or keep it ungraded,
and have a due date if required.
And then you should select which topic
this question is a part of!
And then you can click on ASK!
Your question is now Live
and your students will see it
on their dashboards.
Alright, switching to the student view now!
Students will see the question like this.
They can select the correct answer,
and click on ‘Turn In’.
Once the student answers the question,
she will also be able to see the class summary.
Note that teachers could use this
‘single question option’ in different ways.
Some teachers use it to take a poll,
or may be to support the social
and emotional well-being
of students as well.
Pretty easy wasn’t it?
But what if you want to ask your students
to appear for a quiz
that has say 10 or 15 questions?
You can then select the Quiz Assignment option
you see here!
We will explore this option in the next video!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]